[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a mystery drama film called
love stoppage time spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
takashi aiba is a student working hard
to get into a medical university he is
in one of his classes when suddenly at
quarter past 12 everything around him
stops moving his classmates remain
frozen in their seats and so does his
teacher takashi cannot believe his eyes
he looks around confused and starts to
laugh believing he is being pranked
surely ashton kutcher is waiting around
the corner he walks to the front of the
class unsettled by the silence when he
walks outside and sees the entire school
is frozen he realizes it is not a prank
somehow time has stopped for everyone
except for him takashi gets on his
bicycle and rides to the nearby park as
he travels further he registers he might
be the only person who can move he stops
after seeing droplets of water frozen in
a water fountain when he tries to touch
it the water falls all over him from the
other side of the pond a girl laughs at
him revealing that she can also move
takashi is about to call her but he
suddenly appears back in the class where
he was before time froze he is
completely dry as if he had never gotten
in the pond takashi is shocked at the
experience but cannot tell anyone
because no one would believe him that
night he returns home still thinking
about the strange events of the day he
asks his father about his day but
doesn't get any answers takashi's father
is disappointed in him because he was
unsuccessful in getting into his desired
university the following day at 12 15 pm
he is in the library he bumps into a guy
and sees that the book he dropped has
frozen mid-air realizing that it is
happening again he runs to the park to
meet the girl from yesterday when he
doesn't find her there he goes to her
school that he recognizes from the
uniform she was wearing after looking
for a few minutes he finds her lying
down in the school's garden he wakes her
up but the girl thinks he is a pervert
wrong takashi is a pervert who can stop
time
takashi apologizes and claims that he
looked for her because he felt alone
after finding out they are the only ones
who can move she agrees to accompany him
the pair talks about the time stopping
but has no clue what is causing it and
why they are the ones who can move all
of a sudden the girl notices a driver
has fallen asleep and is about to drive
into some children crossing the road she
tries to wake him up but to no avail
takashi knows no matter what they do to
stop him things will go back to how they
were after the time is reset hence he
looks for the driver's number in the car
and remembers it as soon as the time
resets he calls him hoping to wake the
man up following that he runs to the
location and sees that the children are
safe the girl also arrives there and
praises his quick thinking they promise
to meet again tomorrow before leaving
the girl tells him that her name is
tokine shinomaya the next day they meet
at the park again shinomaya is drawing a
sketch which takashi thinks is useless
because it will disappear when time
resets still shinomaya believes that the
picture will be embedded in her mind so
it doesn't matter the two then go on a
bike ride through the city and end up in
a field as they talk they name the
pausing of the time lost time takashi
wants to spend more time with her but is
too shy to ask her out shinomaya senses
this and says that they should meet the
next day and go on a date later that day
takashi is cooking while singing clearly
in a good mood however it changes when
he notices his father saiji behind him
as they talk we find out that takashi's
mother died of an illness when he was
nine but saiji didn't come to visit her
in the hospital ever since then their
relationship hasn't been the same the
following day shinomaya and takashi meet
at the park for their date she claims
she wants to play on the trampoline
because she is embarrassed to do it when
people are watching takashi watches her
play like a child and cannot help but
smile following that he lays out the
food he has cooked for her at first
shinomaya hesitates to eat it saying
that she is on a diet takashi reminds
her that after the lost time is over she
will go back to being hungry so she can
eat as much as she wants the two enjoy
the food together while talking about
different things eventually they get
into an argument when takashi says he is
giving up on his dreams shinomaya calls
him lazy making him walk away from her
he accidentally pushes her to the ground
when suddenly the time restarts
somewhere else in a hospital dr asami
walks into a room to his sick wife she
has been sick for several years and the
chances of her getting well are low like
sheenamaya she also loves to sketch
asami takes care of her dearly but she
feels like she is a burden to him the
following day takashi is in his room
reading manga when the time stops again
he runs to the park and sees shinomaya
waiting for him both of them apologize
to each other and reconcile they decide
to meet at his home the following day
takashi tells her that his goal in life
is to be a doctor they go for a bicycle
ride and end up in the same field again
takashi moves forward to kiss her but
the time resets just then and he ends up
back in his room in the meantime asami
and his wife's relationship takes a turn
when she says she doesn't want to be
with him anymore he is shocked and asks
her why even though he knows the reason
she tells him that she is being
transferred to a hospice healthcare
place tomorrow and wants to live however
she wants for the time she has left
asami tries to reason with her but she
dismisses him the next day shinomaya
knocks on takashi's door for their date
she's wearing a beautiful dress that
leaves him speechless he welcomes her in
and compliments her which makes
shinomaya blush he has prepared several
dishes for them that excite her before
sitting down to eat he gives her a pair
of fancy chopsticks as a gift the two
enjoy the food in silence later takashi
asks shinomaya what she plans to be in
the future she seems to avoid the
question and talks about a time capsule
that she buried when she was little the
capsule contained papers where she had
written her dreams and aspirations but
she doesn't remember them now takashi
suggests they dig it up but it turns out
that the field is someone's front yard
now after the meal they enjoy a
chocolate cake together takashi invites
her to a firework display that night but
she claims that she cannot see him
anymore a shocked takashi asks her why
but the time resets and he never gets to
know the answer the following day when
time freezes again he looks all around
for her but cannot find her later he
asks her classmates who inform him that
she is in the hospital being treated for
a deadly disease takashi quickly runs to
the hospital and finds out that she has
a condition called wilson's disease the
chances of her survival are low because
only a liver transplant can save her all
of her family have been tested but none
of their liver is a match to her
moreover to perform the transplant the
donor has to be a family member so she
has lost hope for survival she also
reveals that the day she found out that
she won't get a donor was also the day
the lost time started takashi insists he
will take a test to see if his lever
matches hers but shinomaya thinks it is
fruitless when he doesn't back off she
tells him she only has six months to
live so she doesn't want to see him
anymore at home takashi googles wilson's
disease and reads several articles about
it he finds out that a person suffering
from the disease isn't allowed to eat
chocolate shrimp and seaweed everything
that he had been feeding her until now
she know maya was able to enjoy the food
she liked when she was with him after
finding this out he rushes to the
hospital again he walks into dr asami
and asks him to save her at any cost to
his surprise the doctor asks him if time
stops for them as well they go to the
rooftop to talk about the matter it is
then revealed that asami and his wife
also went through the same experience
that takashi and shinomaya are asami's
wife was suffering from a terminal
disease that needed a liver transplant
suddenly the two started to experience
lost time and met each other it was
almost like god's way of telling them
that their livers matched and asami
could help her survive since both pair's
stories are very similar he believes
that takashi's lever will also be a
match to shinomaya however for a living
transplant there are several rules that
need to be followed first of all the
donor must be the recipient's relative
this can be managed if the two get
married but still takashi cannot donate
organs before the age of 20. their last
chance would be to hope that shinomaya
survives for one more year until he can
legally donate his liver but the doctor
claims that she can hardly survive for
six months at the rate her health is
currently deteriorating following the
interaction with asami takashi sits
beside shinomaya looking through her
sketchbook all of her sketches are of
the memories they made together like the
water fountain where they first saw each
other and the lunchbox that he made for
her but what catches his attention is a
sketch of himself takashi is a
narcissist when takashi returns home
that night he asks his father saiji how
his mother was able to survive for more
time than the doctors had predicted he
is informed that she used to say she
won't die before saiji fulfilled his
dream to construct a bridge she held on
for a few months but sadly couldn't see
the finished product during her death
saiji was at the construction site
trying to complete it quickly because it
was the only thing he could do for her
hearing this takashi finally forgives
his father for not being there when she
passed away the next day when time
freezes he goes to the house where
shinomaya had buried her time capsule he
has made it his mission to find the box
no matter what he digs different areas
of the yard each day and keeps track
using a map after digging for several
days he finally finds the box and runs
to the hospital to give it to her
shinomaya says she shouldn't have worked
that hard but she is secretly delighted
to have the box back on looking through
it she finds drawings of her as a baker
a florist and so on takashi also shows
her the sheet that says his liver
matches hers which means they met for a
reason
to her surprise he kneels down and asks
her to marry him shinomaya cries
overwhelmed by the gesture but takashi
promises to save her asami has talked to
the ethics community of the hospital who
allowed takashi to donate under the
consent of his parents he asks
permission from his father urging him to
sign the consent papers he claims that
only 40 percent of his liver will be
used so he will only suffer from mild
discomfort but if it means saving
shinomaya's life he is willing to do
anything still saiji doesn't permit him
to make the reckless decision the
following day is the day takashi and
shinomaya get married the hospital is
being decorated for the ceremony takashi
puts two watches on a platform as a
replacement for their wedding rings
asami comments that he feels like he is
going back in time because his wedding
was very similar to takashi's surprise
his father arrives at the hospital with
signed papers happy that his son has
made a decision to save someone's life
however the story takes a turn when
takashi finds shinomaya unconscious in
her hospital room she is taken to the
icu immediately but the doctors can do
nothing as she goes into a coma takashi
finds a letter addressed to him where
shinomaya thanks him for making her life
better she also expresses her love for
him for the first time in the letter
when the clock hits 12 15 the time
doesn't pause takashi believes that this
means genomia has passed away but the
doctor informs him that there is still a
chance cut to a few weeks later takashi
wakes up on a hospital bed next to
shinomaya after the organ transplant
they both are alive and well the couple
holds hands thankful for their health
somewhere else asami and his wife are
watching the sea asami makes her
understand that she is not a burden on
him in fact she makes his life better
the two reconcile and he assures her he
will find a way for them to be together
again
in the final scene we see takashi and
shinomaya having lunch at the park on
shinomaya's 17th birthday subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching